Tiger 10 ab meldet sich zurück und das
ist der Grund für ein Community Video 2
mit den
Außenseitern er ist die Legende unter
den nutzerfragenstellern und sorgt auch
bei den Außenseitern für eine Menge
Unterhaltung also seid
gespannt Schubkraft 1 fragt machen die
echt nur Videos wir schreiben jetzt auch
Bücher also hier wie seid ihr zu den
Charakter Herbert gekommen meine
Exfreundin zu verdanken damals als wir
zusammen waren hat sie gesagt e du wenn
wir zu in die Disco gehen ziehst du dich
immer so hiphopmäßig an kannst du dir
nicht was cooles anziehen und ich sagte
e komm baby baby komm und suche dir
Kleidung aus und das ist wirklich kein
Witz sie hat diese Sachen ausgesucht
ohne die herbet mit nur nur diesen
gestreiften teil und diese Hosen ja ich
kam dann irgendwann im Laufe des Abends
auf H und sagte du siehst wie ein Spaß
da aus und das ist das ist einfach
witzig und du siehst aus wie mein Bruder
das hat sich dann einfach von alleine
ergeben also diese Figur wir haben auch
natürlich auf Menschen beobartet so
entstehen die meisten Figuren von uns
wir beoben Menschen gucken so welche
negative oder lustige Eigenschaften hat
der Mensch so wie wir die auch habener
hat so eine negative Eigenschaft die man
ein bisschen übertreibt und dann daraus
steht so ein lustiges Produkt wie
Herbert z.B Herbert ist so ein ein
bisschen verplanter Junge der einfach
nichts auf die Reihe bekommt 96 fragt
seid jetzt voll geldgeil geworden und
macht nur noch unnötige Videos für
Klicks deswegen muss ich die Frage
beantworten natürlich bleibt die Meinung
die überlassen ob jetzt geldgeil sind
oder nicht aber je nachdem also es kommt
immer drauf an was der Mensch denkt aber
wir machen die Videos immer noch
wirklich aus Leidenschaft ob du uns das
jetzt abkaufst oder nicht ist natürlich
deine Sache aber ich würde jetzt nicht
sagen dass wir das nur für Klicks machen
jeder macht es für Klicks jeder Youtuber
jeder will Klicks erreichen aber nicht
nur darum geht's uns nicht mein 24 da
fragt was sagt eure Familie zu euren
Videos die freuen sich also die die sind
zufrieden mit uns also die schauen sich
nicht alles an um Gottes Willen zum
Glück schauen die nicht alles an die
sind stolz auf uns dass wir irgendwas
machen aus unserem Leben wir hocken
nicht und warum und trinken Alkohol oder
so wir unterhalten Menschen aber die
verstehen auch nicht alles also um
ehrlich zu sein die verstehen den Humor
nicht wie seid ihr auf den Namen die
Außenseite gekommen wie wir auf den
Namen die Außenseite gekommen sind ist
eigentlich selbsterklärend oder
selbstbeantwortend falls es Wort gibt
die Außenseiter sind wir wirklich schon
immer gewesen sind wir immer noch und
zweite so so eine tiefgründig versteckte
Botschaft ist die Außenseite immer die
ersten Buchstaben D und A demmitri und
Alexander sind unsere Namen man könnte
auch noch ein paar andere so Illuminati
Botschaften da hinein interpretieren
aber das machen wir jetzt mal nicht die
Außenseite sind wir halt das ist das war
das kam einfach so rein weil weil es so
ist 2006 Cherie streitet ihr euch
eigentlich auch manchmal oder geht auch
auf die Nerven PS ihr seid die besten
ihr seid so cool danke schön erstmal
fürs Kompliment ja wir sind auch nur
Menschen und wir streiten uns auch
ziemlich oft eigentlich aber das sind
eigentlich nur so klein Streitigkeiten
und da reden wir auch miteinander und
wir kommen schon wir kommen schon gut
klar also klar man jeder Mensch streitet
sich und das gehört zum Leben dazu aber
gerade in solchen Situationen erfährst
du auch was da andere Menschen über dich
denken das ist schon wichtig auch ab und
zu sich zu streiten zu fighten sich auf
die Fresse zu haauen warum kommt ihr
erst jetzt zu Klick im weitentfernten
Jahre 2010 gab es eine Twit Nachricht
Twitter Nachricht an Christoph von mir
ich habe ihm zugesagt dass wir ein
Interview machen werden ich glaube im
Herbst noch auf jeden Fall dieses Jahr
noch habe ich gesagt 2010 hat aber nicht
funktioniert weil wir einfach zu zu buy
waren zu beschäftigt damals war es eine
richtig krasse Zeit für uns ich habe
meine Ausbildung gemacht und wir haben
diese Videos die ganze Zeit gedreht und
zum Teil haben wir auch ein bisschen
Angst gehabt ehrlich gesagt vor einem
Interview wir haben das nie davor
gemacht das ist eigentlich auch unser
erstes Interview jetzt was wir hier
machen g ich weiß nicht ob ob man uns
das ansieht aber wir sind echt ziemlich
schüchterne Personen ich glaube das
merkt man auch und das war
wahrscheinlich auch der Hauptgrund und
der Rest natürlich auch der also das kam
alles dazu und das war einfach
vielleicht zu viel für uns wir haben
unsere erste Interviews mit 30 geplant
da wir was erzählen wollten wir wir
waren der Meinung wenn du wenn du also
mit Z 3 24 Jahren da Interview machst
bist du noch also hast noch nicht viel
zu erzählen finde ich also persönlich
hallo KCK Hall hi ich grüße alle hier
tigw von Youtube ich WTE alle grüßen ich
habe die AU war eine Frage war ihr
früher wirklich außenseit oder was war
das mit euch oder seid ihr nur so den
Namen nach was ihr seid ihr seid
außenseit ne klar richtig i seid von
außen von der Seite ne oder nicht se von
der Seite von außen und kommt von ganz
links oder von ganz rechts V von vorne
das frage ich mich aus
zurück tschüss tschüss tchüss
[Musik]
hallo vielen dank erstmal für die Frage
von einem etwas außergewöhnlichen
Youtuber deine Frage ich glaube die
haben mir schon mal beantwortet bei dem
Interview jetzt ob wir Außenseiter waren
ja wir waren wirklich Außenseiter das
wissen auch unsere Fans zumindest die
meisten von uns und ich glaube auch dass
du auch ein Außenseiter bist wenn du in
diesem Alter noch auf Youtube rum hängst
also musst bist richtig krass auf jeden
Fall auf jeden Fall cool Respekt wir
haben schon paaron gesehench coes Zeug
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt von deinem
Enkel Gel gelenkt
wird gesteuert wird ja ob der noch
irgendjemand im Spiel ist außer dir aber
cooler Kanal von dir aber schau er kennt
FL er kennt K er kennt Bushido er kennt
alles ja also so ein Mann in diesem
Alter der sich mit so Sachen auskennt
ist schon krass also wenn es wirklich
alles von dir ist Respekt und die zweite
Frage war ob wir von wo wir kommen von
links von rechts von vorne von hinten
glaub wenn man das auf der Karte
betrachtet kommen wir aus Russland also
von rechts würde ich sagen ansonsten
sind wir weniger rechts wir sind auch
nicht links wir sind so neutral würde
ich sagen Danke für die Frage noch mal
und Schuss by und jetzt noch ein Video
für alle Tiger 10 ab Fans mit einem der
größten Fans von Tiger 10 ab nämlich K1
der FE Tiger 10 ab so richtig wenn er
ihn nämlich nach seinen
Frauengeschichten fragt also Tiger 10 ab
K1 nach seinen Frauengeschichten fragt
äh das müsst ihr unbeding angklücken
wenn er da ablachen wollt oder äh sehr
spannend auch die Frage von White Titi
an die Außenseite die nämlich wissen
wollen ob Sascha und Dima als sie
angefangen haben geahnt haben dass es
mal so weit kommen würde das also sehr
interessant und ansonsten äh bis dann
bleibt
dran